Це німецька перукарня.
Сюди, аби привести своє волосся до ладу,
з'їжджаються ледь не зі всього Бонна.
- Прошу.
Підстригтись прийшов і Пітер.
- Можете так? Щоб так стояло.
Юнак стрижеться тут уперше.
Нещодавно приїхав із Польщі.
- А пан звідки?
- З України.
Сергій у Німеччині вже понад 20 років,
із них майже 10 - як не просто перукар, а й бізнесмен.
Ця студія - його.
- Окей?
- Супер.
- Скільки?
- Чотирнадцять.
Вести бізнес і працювати одночасно, зізнається, нелегко.
Тим паче, коли за день обслуговує з десяток клієнтів.
Хизується: має і поважних гостей.
- Ми починаємо стригти з року.
Найстаршій клієнтці, здається, вже 102 роки.
Про перукарство, каже, не думав ніколи.
Школу закінчив у 90-му році і мріяв стати істориком. Але...
- Версія комуністичної історії викликала в мене протест.
Історія для мене закінчилася.
Археологічні розкопки я зараз проводжу в волоссі.
Отримав диплом перукаря в Чернігівському училищі й мігрував у Бонн.
Спершу керував чужою перукарнею,
у 36 років відкрив свою.
Сергій запевняє: робиться це легко.
- У Німеччині це вітається.
Якщо людина сама хоче працювати, ще й дати таку можливість іншим.
Усе, що треба, - легально перебувати на території країни,
відкрити банківський рахунок і прийти з паспортом
на консультацію в міську адміністрацію чи одразу в ремісничу палату.
- Я маю дозвіл на цей вид діяльності.
Ось так виглядає ліцензія.
Її оформлення коштуватиме від 15 до 60 євро.
Потрібна вона для торгових професій.
Представникам же вільних, таких як художники,
досить лише стати на податковий облік.
Відкриття перукарні Сергію обійшлося у 20-25 тисяч євро.
Це і власні кошти, і позичені у друзів.
Якщо взяти гроші ніде, можна написати бізнес-план
і піти в банк за кредитом.
- Якщо ви відкриваєте бізнес одразу,
берете на роботу людей, даєте робочі місця, то,
мені здається, майже одразу 30% кредиту списуються.
Після сплати всіх податків, Сергій каже, мільйонером не станеш.
Тим паче, за його словами, перукарство -
одна з найменш оплачуваних професій у Німеччині.
За місяць на руки отримує кілька тисяч євро.
- Від трьох-чотирьох тисяч.
Утім, на шляху до відкриття своєї справи
може з’явитися типова для Німеччини перешкода.
Щоб відкрити, наприклад, ось таке кафе,
доведеться довго шукати приміщення.
Із такою проблемою зіткнулася й українка Анна.
Вона пече торти і мріє про свою кондитерську в Бонні.
Вже точно знає, якою вона буде.
- Це дерево, багато білого, дуже натуральні матеріали.
Дуже мрію про залізні столи, бо їх дуже легко мити,
на них можна ставити гаряче, різати на них.
Раніше дівчина працювала в Єврокомісії та ООН,
та під час декретної відпустки відчула: хоче випікати.
Спершу вчилася сама, потім поїхала на курси в Італію.
Уже майже рік тренується на малесенькій домашній кухні.
- Можу тобі дати попробувати крем.
- Бувають креми, які тут літають, як гранати.
Дівчина створила сторінку в соцмережі, куди
публікує фото своїх кулінарних шедеврів.
Тут є навіть спеціальний торт на честь міських сакур.
- Такий signature cake for Bonn.
Наразі торти їдуть до чоловіка на роботу, бо
з'їсти все самі не можуть, а продавати Аня їх поки не має права.
Хоча за один такий пляцок можна було б отримати кругленьку суму.
- Думаю, десь від 70 євро.
Аня впевнена: кондитерська була б прибутковою.
- В Україні цього дуже багато, а коли починаєш тут шукати,
то цього тут дуже мало.
Але оформити це як бізнес поки не може, бо
попереду ще санітарні тренінги, де навчать
правильно зберігати й обробляти продукти та доглядати за кухнею.
- Те, куди мене направили - це департамент по здоров’ю,
департамент по продуктах харчування, безпеці.
Ну і оренда...
- Конкретно зараз іти реєструватися,
не маючи приміщення, наприклад,
навіть на цій кухні я би не стала, тому що
тут я навіть не можу поставити ще один холодильник.
На пошуки Аня витратила вже пів року.
Каже, в місті нічого просто не здається,
а до кухонного приміщення ще й є спеціальні вимоги.
- Це має бути дві мийки, підлога, яка добре миється,
відповідний холодильник, витяжка.
Для кафе доведеться підназбирати грошей.
- Наприклад, таке найпростіше кафе, якщо не в себе вдома,
то це хоча б 50 тисяч доларів, ой євро, треба мати.
Це обладнання, ремонт приміщення і якісь там
перші місяці оплати оренди.
Ну, а поки її випічка проходить посилену дегустацію.